In this course, I will show you how to identify
and fix WordPress performance issues for good.
And much of what I teach about performance
applies to non-WordPress websites as well.
So there will be something for everyone.
My name is Beau Carnes.
I've created popular courses about many topics
including WordPress, Python, JavaScript, and more.
Now I'm gonna teach you how to improve
the performance of your website.
InMotion Hosting provided a grant
to make this course possible.
They provide secure and reliable web hosting,
but you don't need to use their hosting
to implement the tips I share in this course.
InMotion Hosting has also made a tier three VPS
with WordPress installed available
as a free one month trial for anyone following along
with this course at home.
Here are the top steps you can take right now
to get immediate results.
We'll be covering all of these in this course.
Setting your performance goals,
understanding a website request,
DNS configuration and CDNs,
server configuration and tuning for WordPress,
caching techniques,
and optimizing the WordPress application.
Monitoring and adjusting website performance
is a critical factor in the success of any website
and optimizing your website for speed
should be a top priority.
This course is an invaluable resource
for anyone looking to optimize their website's performance
and gain a competitive edge in the online marketplace.
By following the practical advice
and best practices outlined in this course,
you can improve your website's performance
and provide your users with a fast, efficient,
and enjoyable online experience.
First, let's talk about setting your performance goals.
Determining goals for optimizing website speed
and performance is critical to achieving desired outcomes.
Here are some steps to help you establish clear goals
and objectives.
Define your purpose.
Start by understanding why you want to optimize
your site's speed and performance.
Is it to enhance user experience, reduce bounce rates,
improve conversion rates,
or achieve better search engine rankings?
Clarifying your purpose will guide
your goal setting process.
Analyze current performance.
Use tools like Google Lighthouse,
Google PageSpeed Insights,
Google Search Console, or Web Page Test
to evaluate your website's current speed and performance.
Identify areas where improvements are needed,
such as slow loading times, excessive page weight,
or high server response times.
These insights will help you prioritize
and set specific goals.
Prioritize metrics.
Determine which performance metrics
are most important for your website.
Common metrics include page load time,
time to first byte,
render start time, and interactive time.
Line these metrics with your purpose
to identify the most critical areas for improvement.
Set measurable targets.
Establish specific, measurable, achievable,
relevant, and time-bound goals, or smart goals.
For example, set a goal to reduce page load time
by 30% within three months,
or achieve a TTFB of under 20 milliseconds.
Clear targets will provide a benchmark for progress
and help you stay focused.
Consider user expectations.
Understand your target audience's expectations
and browsing behavior.
Different websites may require different levels
of optimization based on their user base.
Consider factors like device usage, mobile versus desktop,
geographic location, and connection speeds
to tailor your goals accordingly.
Break it down.
Divide your optimization goals
into smaller, actionable tasks.
For instance, optimize image sizes,
minifying CSS and JavaScript,
leveraging browser caching,
or implementing a content delivery network.
Breaking down goals into manageable steps
makes them more achievable
and allows for incremental improvements.
Monitor and iterate.
Regularly monitor your website's performance
using performance monitoring tools or website analytics.
Track progress toward your goals
and identify areas that need further optimization.
Continuously iterate your strategies
to adapt to changing technologies and user expectations.
By following these steps,
you can establish well-defined goals
for optimizing your website's speed and performance.
Remember, the goals should be aligned
with your website's purpose,
be measurable and adaptable to evolving needs.
Before I talk more about how to optimize websites,
let's look at an unoptimized site.
We'll see how the site performs now,
and throughout the course, we'll optimize the site.
Then we'll see how it performs at the end.
So here's a site that's already set up on InMotion Central.
This is a WordPress site,
and here's actually the preview of the site,
the Sprout Invoices.
So this is the settings you get
when you have your WordPress site
hosted on InMotion Central.
You have the preview of the site.
You get your site stats, the URL.
You can also manage the server from here,
and you can do stuff for the plugin themes,
and we have a whole section of optimization
that we'll be talking more about later.
And you can also access the WordPress admin page
right from here.
So the website is going to look like this.
And now let's check out the performance.
First of all, I've turned off this plugin,
so it's not gonna have any just normal optimization,
and we'll talk more about this plugin later.
Now I'm at the PageSpeed Insights website,
the pagespeed.web.dev.
This is from Google,
and it helps you check the performance of your website.
So I'm just gonna get my URL here,
and analyze.
So if we scroll down,
we can see the performance is only in the 47th percentile.
Though we do have some better scores in these other areas,
100th percentile accessibility.
So if we scroll down even further,
we can see what were the bad things.
So anything red is something that's a low performance.
First Contentful Paint,
Largest Contentful Paint, Total Blocking Time, Speed Index,
and we'll actually be talking about all of these things
a little more later.
So if you scroll down, we can get more details,
and it's showing a lot of things that could be improved.
These are all the different opportunities,
and it's showing how we can improve the site.
And so this is kind of a good starting point
for any website,
you just go to this PageSpeed Insights,
and it will give you some ideas on how to improve the site.
Now throughout the rest of this course,
we'll be going through a lot of these things in more detail.
The mobile score is a little different
than the desktop score,
because it's emulating a mobile device
and the network speeds.
So on desktop, the performance is a little better.
We're at 79, still not in the green range,
which is what we would want.
But that is a little better,
but you want to design all of your websites.
So they have good performance,
both on desktop and mobile.
But again, you can see all these things
that you can improve on.
Now let's talk about performance testing tools.
There are many testing tools available online
to gauge your website performance.
In this section, we want to get a website
to rank better on Google,
so we will use Google's tools to achieve our goals.
There are also some other pretty awesome optimization tools,
such as GTmetrics, Pingdom, and many others.
Before we explain how to assess your site prior to optimizing,
let's go over a quick outline of how the different pieces
are weighted in the Lighthouse tests.
The Lighthouse score calculator
gives us information at a glance
and even allows you to plug in your own scores
to understand how your overall page speed score is calculated.
Inside Chrome's developer tools, or dev tools,
you can use the code inspector
to get to the open source extension for Google Lighthouse.
It's helpful because it runs tests right within your browser,
and it generates a report for you
on how well the website you are looking at
stacks up for both mobile and desktop versions.
This test gives you information about performance,
accessibility, best practices, and SEO.
And here's a tip.
When performing a test with dev tools,
you want to use an incognito window or a guest account,
as browser extensions typically interfere with the test
and skew the results.
PageSpeed Insights is an online tool that tests your site
and then delivers a score for both mobile devices
and desktop computers.
You'll see a score and a breakdown of the metrics
used to determine your site performance.
PSI, that's PageSpeed Insights,
will also provide a breakdown of the issues,
causing any slowdowns to the performance of your site.
Recommendations are provided on actions you can take
to improve the performance.
PSI uses simulations and real-world data
when available to provide its scores.
The Chrome User Experience Report
is also called the Core Web Vitals metric.
This is an aggregate of user experience metrics
that is compiled from actual users
that visit your website over the last 28 days.
The data is not comprehensive, however.
These users are limited to people that have opted
to sync their browser history with Chrome,
and the data is made available by PageSpeed Insights,
Google's BigQuery project, and Data Studio.
While it's helpful information when optimizing your website
for speeding performance, it's not representative
of everyone's experience with your site.
The Page Experience Report in Google's Search Console
provides you with a summary of their measurement
for your visitor's user experience.
Google evaluates these metrics for individual URLs
on your website and will use them as a ranking signal
in search results.
This report covers Core Web Vitals,
mobile usability, and HTTPS usage
for every page that you have in Google's index.
In order for a page to be counted in this report's data,
it must have data in the Core Web Vitals report simultaneously.
We should mention other tools as well
because this is by no means an exhaustive list.
In short, there are a ton of professional tools
that you can use to measure your website's performance,
such as GTmetrics, Pingdom, Web Page Test, and more.
Any tool you use will guide you with things that need to be done
to improve your website's speed.
There are many factors that will impact the score you see on these tests.
These variables can range from your location related to the website,
activity on your server, network routes,
and even the activity on your local computer.
Because of these and many other factors,
no two tests will show the exact same results.
However, with a little persistence,
you can minimize the impact that your server and website
bring into the equation.
Simply follow these suggestions,
learn about them, and implement best practices.
This will increase the likelihood that your visitors
will have a good user experience.
When testing your website's performance
and putting together your plan of attack,
the tool you use will dictate the metrics used in the audit.
Here are the top performance indicators to pay attention to.
I recommend focusing on achieving passing green scores on Core Web Vitals
before you move on to the other performance metrics.
So you can just check out this chart that we have on the screen now.
The key to success for your website is to focus on the user experience.
Google's Core Web Vitals are a set of metrics
that measure real-world user experience for loading performance,
interactivity, and visual stability of the page.
These metrics are designed to help you understand
how good the user experience is on your site
compared to other sites on the web.
Core Web Vitals are broken down into a subset of page experience signals
that apply to all websites and should be measured by website owners.
The metrics that make up the Core Web Vitals
are subject to evolve over time as the signals are not set in stone
and are intended to change as time passes
to continue improving the overall user experience on the web.
Page experience signals and Core Web Vitals
are the best signals that developers have
to measure and improve the quality of the user experience
and they're broken down into largest contentful paint,
first input delay, and cumulative layout shift.
You can outline what each signal is
and share some best practices and steps to take
to ensure you improve your website's performance
in relation to each metric.
Tools that measure Core Web Vitals
consider a page to be passing if it meets the recommended target
for of 75th percentile for all three metrics.
Largest Contentful Paint measures your website's loading performance
in order to provide a good user experience for your visitors,
or LCP, that's Largest Contentful Paint,
should occur within 2.5 seconds of the initial page loading.
The types of elements that are considered for Largest Contentful Paint
are usually images or videos.
It is important to understand that an element
can only be considered the LCP once it is rendered
and the user can see it.
This metric is also tied to the first Contentful Paint
which measures how long it takes for the initial DOM content to render.
But First Contentful Paint does not account for how long
it takes the largest and usually more important content
on the page to render.
So Largest Contentful Paint represents a user's perception
of loading experience.
And the Lighthouse performance score weighting is 25%.
What it measures?
The point in the page load time when the page's largest image
or text block is visible within the viewpoint.
How it's measured?
Lighthouse extracts LCP data from Chrome's tracing tool.
And is Largest Contentful Paint a Web Core Vital?
Yes.
So what elements are part of the Largest Contentful Paint?
Well, image elements, image elements inside an SVG element,
video elements, an element with a background image
loaded via the URL function,
block line elements containing text nodes
or other inline level text elements children.
And here's how to define the LCP using Chrome DevTools.
First open the page in Chrome,
then navigate to the performance panel of the DevTools.
You can use command option I on Mac
or a control shift I on Windows and Linux.
Then you hover over the LCP marker in the timing section.
And finally, the elements that correspond to LCP
is detailed in the related node field.
So what causes poor LCP?
Poor LCP typically comes from four issues,
slow server response time,
render blocking JavaScript and CSS,
resource load times and client side rendering.
Now let's talk about how you can improve LCP.
The usual suspects of a poor LCP can be caused by many things.
Some of the causes can be slow response times from the server,
render blocking JavaScript and CSS,
slow resource load times and even client rendering.
Slow server response times is the first thing you should tackle
when optimizing for performance.
Faster server response will typically impact
and improve every page loading measurement, including LCP.
If the cause is slow server response time,
you need to optimize your server,
route users to a nearby CDN,
cache assets,
survey HTML page,
cache first,
and establish third party connections early.
If the cause is render blocking JavaScript and CSS,
you want to minify the CSS,
defer non-critical CSS,
inline critical CSS,
minify and compress JavaScript files,
defer unused JavaScript,
and minimize unused polyfills.
If the cause is resource load times,
you want to optimize and compress images,
preload important resources,
compress textiles,
deliver different assets based on the network connection,
and cache assets using a service worker.
Finally, if the cause is client-side rendering,
you want to minimize critical JavaScript
or use another rendering strategy.
Okay, first input delay, or FID,
measures a website's interactivity
and focus on input events from discrete actions
like clicks, taps, and key presses.
When a website does not respond in a certain amount of time
after a user interaction,
users experience this as a lag or slowdown.
To provide a good user experience,
your web pages should have a FID of 100 milliseconds or less.
So what this represents is your user's first impression
of your site's interactivity and responsiveness.
It doesn't apply to the Lighthouse performance score.
What it measures is the time when a user first interacts with your site,
when they click a link, tap a button,
or use a custom JavaScript power control
to the time when the browser is actually able to respond to that interaction.
How is measured?
It requires a real user and thus cannot be measured in the lab.
However, the total blocking time metric is lab measurable
and can be used as a proxy as it correlates well with FID in the field
and also captures issues that affect interactivity.
And is this a web core vinyl?
Yes.
So what causes poor FID?
The main cause is heavy JavaScript execution.
Optimizing how JavaScript parses, compiles, and executes on your web page
will directly reduce FID.
How to improve it?
Well, you can reduce the impact of third-party script execution,
reduce JavaScript execution time,
like by deferring unused JavaScript or minimizing unused polyfills,
can break up long tasks,
optimize your page for interaction readiness,
use a web worker, minimize main thread work,
or finally keep request counts low and transfer sizes small.
Also, you should note that FID is being replaced by INP in March of 2024.
INP is interaction to next paint.
Cumulative layout shift or CLS measures visual stability.
A good user experience is measured as having a CLS of 0.1 or less.
This allows the experience to avoid any surprises for the user,
but isn't particularly helpful for page speed.
It's more measurement that your website is following best practices
and is a necessary piece for achieving a high performance score for your page.
These best practices including following common UX patterns
that are optimized for CLS.
When your page is loading, you should always be sure to set size attributes or reserve space.
Specifically, specify the width or height attributes
to create a placeholder for a content.
This will help ensure your page does not jitter and move for the customer
while they're trying to interact with it.
Your website should never insert content above existing content
unless a user interacts and expects the behavior.
And you should always use transformation animations
when transforming the layout during said interactions.
So what it represents?
The visual stability of a page.
Instability is defined as unexpected movement or page content
as the user is trying to interact with the page.
And it's 15% of the Lighthouse performance score weighting.
What it measures?
It measures the largest burst of layout shift scores
for every unexpected layout shift that occurs during the entire lifespan of a page.
A layout shift occurs any time a visual element changes its position
from one rendered frame to the next.
How it's measured?
To calculate the layout shift score,
the browser looks at the viewport size
and the movement of unstable elements in the viewport between two rendered frames.
The layout shift score is a product of two measures of that movement.
The impact fraction and the distance fraction.
And is this a core, a web core value?
Yes.
So let's look at how to see CLS using Chrome DevTools.
Use DevTools to help debug layout shifts
by leveraging the experience pane under the performance panel.
The summary view for a layout shift record
includes the cumulative layout shift score
as well as a rectangle overlay showing the affected regions.
What causes poor layout shifts?
Changes to the position of a DOM element.
This is often the result of style sheets that are loaded late
or overwrite previously declared style
or delays in animation and transition effects.
Also changes to the dimension of a DOM element.
This is often the result of images, ads, embeds, and iframes without dimensions.
Or insertion of or removal of a DOM element.
Another cause is animations that trigger layout.
This is often the result of insertion of ads and other third party embeds,
insertion of banners, alerts, and modals,
infinite scroll and other UX patterns that load additional content
above existing content.
Or finally, another cause is actions waiting for a network response
before updating the DOM.
And how you can improve it?
Always set attributes to images and video elements
or allocate the correct amount of space for that element while it's loading.
Also, never insert content above existing content
except during an intentional user interaction.
And prefer transform animations to animations of properties
that trigger layout changes.
Finally, preload fonts using the link rel preload on the key web fonts
and combine link rel preload with font display optional.
Another performance opportunity is first contentful paint.
This measures the time to render the first piece of the DOM content.
It represents the amount of time it takes the browser to render
the first piece of DOM content after a user navigates to your page.
Images, non-white canvas elements, and SVGs on your page
are considered DOM element, DOM content.
This is 10% of the Lighthouse performance score.
What it measures?
This is a user centric metric for measuring perceived load speed
because it marks the first point in the page load timeline
where the user can see anything on the screen.
How it's measured?
The score is a comparison of your page's first contentful paint time
and the first contentful paint times for real websites
based on data from the HTTP archive.
It is not a web core vital.
Here are some ways to improve the first contentful paint.
Eliminate render blocking resources.
Minify CSS.
Remove unused CSS.
Preconnect to required origins.
Reduce server response times.
Avoid multiple page redirects.
Preload key requests.
Avoid enormous network payloads.
Serve static assets with an efficient cache policy.
Avoid an excessive DOM size.
Minimize critical request depth.
Insert text remains visible during web font load.
Keep request counts low and transfer sizes small.
Another thing to think about is the speed index, the SI.
This represents the average time at which visible parts of the page are displayed.
It's 10% of the Lighthouse performance score weighting.
What it measures?
The speed index measures how quickly content is visually displayed during page load.
Lighthouse first captures a video of the page loading in the browser
and computes the visual progression between frames.
How it's measured?
The speed index score is a comparison of your page's speed index
and the speed indices of real websites based on data from the HTTP archive.
It is not a web core vital.
Here's some things you can do to improve speed index.
Minimize main thread work.
Reduce JavaScript execution time.
Ensure text remains visible during web font load.
Eliminate render blocking resources.
Another thing to think about is the total blocking time, or TBT.
This represents the total amount of time that a page is blocked from responding to user input,
such as mouse clicks, screen taps, or keyboard presses.
It's 30% of the Lighthouse performance score weighting.
What it measures?
This measures the time between first contentful paint and time to interactive.
It is the lab equivalent of first input delay,
the field data used in the Chrome user experience report
and Google's page experience ranking signal.
How it's measured?
The total time in which the main thread is occupied by tasks
taking more than 50 milliseconds to complete.
If a task takes 80 milliseconds to run,
30 milliseconds of that time will be counted toward the TBT, the total blocking time.
If a task takes 45 milliseconds to run, 0 milliseconds will be added.
Is total blocking time a web core vital?
Yes.
It's the data, it's the lab data equivalent of first input delay.
Total blocking time measures long tasks,
those tasks taking longer than 50 milliseconds.
When a browser loads your site,
there is essentially a single line queue of scripts waiting to be executed.
Any input from the user has to go into that same queue.
When the browser can't respond to user input because other tasks are executing,
the user perceives this as lag.
Essentially, long tasks are like that person at your favorite coffee shop
who takes far too long to order a drink.
Like someone ordering a 2% venti, four pump vanilla, five pump mocha, whole fat froth,
long tasks are a major source of bad experiences.
Some things that cause a TBT on your page are heavy JavaScript and heavy CSS.
And that's basically it.
Here's how to see TBT using Chrome DevTools.
And how to improve TBT, you can break up long tasks,
optimize your page for interaction readiness,
use web worker, and reduce JavaScript execution time.
Now let's talk about time to first byte or TTFB.
This is a foundational metric for measuring the time between the requests for a resource
and when the first byte of a response begins to arrive.
It helps identify when a web server is too slow to respond to requests.
TTFB is the sum of the following request phases.
Redirect time, server worker startup time,
DNS lookup, connection TLS negotiation,
and request up to the point at which the first byte of the response has arrived.
So here are some ways to improve TTFB.
Hosting web servers with inadequate infrastructure to handle high traffic loads,
web servers with insufficient memory that can lead to thrashing,
unoptimized database tablets, suboptimal database server configuration,
avoid multiple page requests,
pre-connect to required origins for cross-origin resources,
submit your origin to the HSTS preload list to eliminate HTTP to HTTPS redirect latency,
use HTTP2 or HTTP slash 3,
and use server-side generation for markup instead of SSR where possible and appropriate.
Minimizing TTFB starts with choosing a suitable hosting provider with infrastructure
to ensure high uptime and responsiveness.
This, in combination with a CDN, can help significantly.
In this section, we'll discuss how the speed of a request to a website
impacts overall website performance.
When a user makes a request to load a website,
a series of processes happen behind the scenes
to deliver the requested content to the user's browser.
This process can be broken down into the following steps.
Step 1, DNS lookup. The domain name system is a distributed database
that maps domain names to IP addresses.
When a user types a URL into the browser,
the browser first sends a request to a DNS server
to look up the IP address of the domain name.
Step 2, connection.
Once the browser has the IP address of the website,
it establishes a connection to the server hosting the website
using the Hypertext Transfer Protocol, or HTTP.
Or the more secure HTTPS protocol, the S stands for secure.
Step 3, request.
After establishing the connection,
the browser sends an HTTP request to the server
requesting the specific webpage or resource
that the user wants to access.
Step 4, processing.
The server receives a request and begins to process it.
This may involve executing scripts, querying databases,
and retrieving files from the file system.
Step 5, response.
Once the server has processed the request,
it sends an HTTP response back to the browser.
This response includes the requested content,
such as the HTML, CSS, and JavaScript,
and any images or other resources required to display the website.
Step 6, rendering.
The browser receives the response from the server
and begins to render the webpage.
This involves parsing the HTML and rendering the layout,
styling the page with CSS, executing JavaScript,
and loading any images or other resources
required to display the page.
Step 7, user interaction.
Finally, the user can interact with the webpage,
clicking on links, filling out forms,
and performing other actions.
These steps happen very quickly,
often in a matter of milliseconds,
but any delay or bottleneck in any of these steps
can cause the page to load slowly or not at all,
leading to a poor user experience.
To optimize website performance,
it's important to identify and address any performance issues
at each stage of the process.
Some of the WordPress optimizations
have to happen right on the server.
So let me show you how to manage your server in Inmost and Central.
Now, there will be a similar process,
even if you're using another hosting provider.
I'll go to Tools, then Manage Server.
And then we can see the host name, the IP address,
and then we can see that it's currently running.
Now, you can see we can use this to restart or stop the server,
but what we want to do is add our SSH key.
That's going to allow us to connect to our server
from our local machine.
SSH keys are used to securely authenticate with the server
so we can connect via the command line interface.
This is usually the preferred method for advanced users
to manage their servers,
since you can quickly make changes without having to navigate
through a graphical user interface.
So to get our SSH key, we're going to have to generate one.
So you can open a terminal on your local computer,
and then we can type in ssh slash keygen or dash.
Okay, then press Enter,
and it's going to ask us to enter the file,
where to save the key, and we'll just press Enter again.
And mine already exists, so I'm not going to override it,
but if you haven't created it before,
that's what it would show you.
And now we can get it by a copy where the key is,
and then I'll do cat,
and then just put the location.pub.
And then we can see the whole key here.
And then I can just copy this key.
So I'll go to add SSH key,
and then I will just paste in my public key, and then update.
And now we will be able to connect to the server via SSH.
So I need my IP address.
So I'll just copy this IP address,
or actually I'll just copy the host name here.
Now we'll go back to a terminal SSH root at,
and then the server name, or you could also use the IP address,
and then we'll just hit enter here.
And here we want to put yes, we are sure we want to continue.
Okay, we're logged into the host, we're logged into the server.
These tips explain what measures can be taken with Redis,
MySQL, Opcache, and other technologies
to achieve a high performance server.
There are many opportunities to improve performance.
I'll focus on fast storage and emphasize tuning the cache.
Accessing files from NVMe storage, storing PHP scripts and Opcache,
and compressing responses with Brotly
are all part of a high performance server.
I'm going to show you how to analyze your server performance
and make incremental improvements.
Services like Redis and Memcache
can significantly improve WordPress performance
by caching data in memory
and reducing the number of database calls required to serve content.
They act as key value stores
that temporarily hold frequently accessed or computationally expensive data,
resulting in faster response times and reduced server load.
WordPress can be configured to use Redis as an object store
by employing specific plugins,
such as Redis Object Cache or W3 Total Cache.
So once Redis is installed and configured,
you can check the following items to ensure Redis is optimized
and operating its full capacity.
Right now I'm connected to my server through InMotion,
the server that has the WordPress installations installed
and already has Redis installed.
So I can check the Redis memory usage with this command,
Redis CLI info memory.
And then we get all this information.
So if I go scroll up a little bit,
when the used memory peak is close to the max memory that's shown further down,
Redis may not have enough resources to operate to its full capacity.
In addition, Redis may be actually evicting keys from the cache
to make room for new ones.
This is not ideal and key evictions should be avoided if possible.
So you can increase the max memory variable in your Redis configuration
to solve the issue.
And here are where the configuration files are.
If you make any changes,
make sure to restart everything to apply your changes.
Key eviction.
Key eviction is the process of removing old and unused data from the cache
to make room for new data.
This can be especially problematic for high traffic websites
that rely on Redis caching to improve performance.
If your system resources allows for it
and the evicted keys count is high,
it's again recommended to increase max memory.
The following command will provide information about the number of keys
and how many have been evicted.
By examining these aspects and making the appropriate adjustments,
you can optimize Redis to significantly enhance your WordPress site's performance.
Optimize the database.
If object caching like Redis is not available for the WordPress site,
requests for database content go straight to the database.
First, the database checks its cache to serve the results directly, if possible,
and stores it for future use.
If caching is unavailable or not allowed,
the query proceeds to the database.
The database combines cached and uncached information,
requesting data from the operating system.
The speed of retrieving the data depends on available RAM
and the storage type, with NVMe being the fastest and HDD being the slowest.
Simple queries return data immediately to the PHP call,
while complex queries requiring temp tables demand more processing time
and can slow down the website or cause server issues under high traffic.
Several tuning techniques can improve performance.
You can set the buffer pool size.
The buffer pool is the area of memory that MariaDB uses to cache data and indexes.
It's important to configure the buffer pool size appropriately
based on the amount of available memory and the size of the database.
The buffer pool size can be controlled using the
nodb underscore buffer underscore pool underscore size variable.
You can start with 128 or 256 megabytes,
depending on the total available RAM on your server.
Check the hit rate and adjust accordingly to ensure it's working as expected.
You can see here where the configuration files are,
and always make sure to restart your services to apply any of your changes after you configure this.
One way to analyze buffer pool performance is by observing
the nodb underscore buffer underscore pool underscore weight underscore free status variable.
If it's decreasing, then you don't have enough buffer pool,
or your or your flushing isn't occurring frequently enough.
In this case, you should set the nodb underscore buffer underscore pool underscore size variable higher
if your system resources allows for it.
You can also enable query cache.
Query cache is a feature that stores the results of frequently executed queries and memory,
which can significantly improve query performance.
It's recommended to enable query cache,
but it's important to note that it may not be effective for all workloads.
The query cache can be enabled or disabled using the query underscore cache underscore type variable.
The SQL server store stats about the query cache.
Query cache is actually deprecated in MySQL,
but it still exists in MariaDB.
Query cache has taken a less desirable place in most MySQL setups,
because of the high adoption of multi core and multi server deployments,
where it can be a bottleneck.
For Mario DB, it's still useful for websites and fits well in our use case,
where the deployment consists of a single site on the server.
Q cache underscore inserts contains the number of queries added to the query cache.
And Q cache underscore hits contains the number of queries that have made use of the query cache,
while Q cache underscore low mem underscore prunes contains the number of queries
that were dropped from the cache due to lack of memory.
The example could indicate a poorly performing cache.
More queries have been added and more queries have been dropped than have actually been used.
You can set in memory table size limits.
As previously mentioned, complex queries will cause the SQL server to create temporary tables.
The SQL server will attempt to create tables in memory up to a certain size for performance.
It's important to set the max size to an appropriate value to avoid creating on disk temporary tables.
The variables that control this behavior are the tmp underscore table underscore size
and max underscore heap underscore table underscore size.
You can compare the number of internal on disk temporary tables created
to the total number of internal temporary tables created
by comparing the created underscore tmp underscore disk underscore tables
and created underscore tmp underscore tables values.
You can see if it's necessary to increase by comparing the status variables
created underscore tmp underscore disk underscore tables and created underscore tmp underscore tables
to see how many temporary tables out of the total created needed to be converted to disk.
In this example, the SQL server is not having to create temporary tables on disk.
This is considered optimal.
Another thing you can do is to prune the WordPress database.
Without intervention, WordPress will store junk and unused data in the database.
Over time, this can add up causing database bloat and serious performance lags.
This includes items such as post revisions,
which includes autosaved drafts, trashed posts, trashed comments, comment spam,
and tables for plugins and themes that are no longer active or installed, and transient records.
In your wp-config.php file, add or edit the following setting
to limit the number of post revisions saved to the database.
Many resources exist on the internet for dealing with these items.
Monitor performance.
It's important to regularly monitor the performance of Mario DB and adjust the configurations as necessary.
This includes monitoring CPU usage, memory usage, disk IO, and query performance.
Use a tool like MySQL Tuner to gain insights on the performance of the SQL installation,
or enable slow query logging to identify long-running queries.
Opcache provides significant benefits when used with PHP FPM.
When a PHP file has been previously requested and there's enough opcache available,
the script is already stored in memory.
This allows for faster execution as it stands ready to accept data inputs without having to reload the file from disk.
It's important to maximize opcache hits and minimize misses.
And here are where the configuration files are.
If you make any changes, make sure to restart everything to apply your changes.
For opcache, WordPress plugins are available that are restricted by auth.
Standalone opcache dashboard pages need additional security,
but WordPress plugins are behind authentication already.
PHP provides several built-in functions to obtain information about opcache status and configuration,
like opcache underscore get underscore status and opcache underscore get underscore configuration.
Additionally, there are several web-based monitoring tools to visualize opcache usage and performance.
Some popular options include opcache GUI,
which is a single file PHP script that provides a simple and clean interface to monitor opcache usage and performance.
And then there's OCP, which is a web-based opcache control panel
that allows you to monitor and manage opcache settings in real time.
Opcache status, which is a one-page opcache status page for the PHP 5.5 opcode cache,
and cache tool, which allows you to work with APCU opcache
and the file status cache through the CLI.
It will connect to a fast CGI server like PHP FPM and operate on its cache.
When reviewing opcache statistics, there are a few key items to look for and assess.
Opcache hit rate.
A hit rate is the percentage of requests that are being served using cached opcode
instead of parsing and compiling the scripts anew.
This hit rate suggests opcache requires more memory or resources to perform its full capacity.
A hit rate close to 100 indicates that the cache is functioning effectively
and providing the desired performance benefits.
Monitoring the hit rate can help identify if adjustments to opcache settings
are necessary to improve its efficiency.
The next section will explain how to adjust the memory allocation for opcache.
Memory consumption.
Analyzing memory usage involves checking the amount of memory allocated to the opcache
and how much of it is being used.
In the output you can see here, the administrator would want to consider
increasing the opcache.memory underscore consumption to a value higher than 128 megabytes
as the cache full boolean is true and free memory is at 8 bytes.
This information helps determine if there is a need to increase or decrease the memory allocation
based on the size and complexity of your PHP scripts.
Ensuring an appropriate memory allocation helps prevent cache evictions
and promotes a more efficient use of server resources.
Both numcache keys and maxcache keys are metrics that provide insights into the number of cache keys
compiled PHP scripts currently stored in the opcache, the numcache keys
and the maximum number of cache keys allowed, the maxcache keys.
By comparing these values you can identify if the cache is nearing its capacity
or if adjustments are needed to optimize the cache size.
If numcache keys frequently approaches maxcache keys, it can be beneficial to increase
the opcache.maxacceleratedfiles value to accommodate more scripts
reducing cache evictions and further improving performance.
Regularly reviewing these key items can help you optimize the opcache configuration
leading to improved website performance and reduced server resource usage.
As previously mentioned in the database optimization section,
NVMe storage helps database server performance by providing significantly faster
data access and reduced latency compared to traditional storage solutions.
This results in quicker response times and more efficient query processing
leading to improved overall server performance.
Disk I.O. helps increase performance of all aspects of your web server
and having NVMe speeds usually means that the database caching
in W3.12 cache plugin is not needed
and it can have adverse effects to performance if enabled.
NVMe storage improves server performance for WordPress websites in several ways.
Faster page load times.
With its high speed data transfer and load latency, NVMe storage allows
for quicker access to website files and assets such as images, style sheets, and scripts.
This leads to faster page load times and a better user experience.
Improved database performance.
The benefits of using NVMe storage when processing database queries
can be outlined as follows.
When processing queries, the database relies on both cached and uncached
MySQL data requiring interactions with the operating system to retrieve
the necessary information.
If the operating system has ample RAM,
the files needed for a query might already be stored in RAM
rather than only being available on a persistent storage device.
Finally, in cases where data must be accessed from a storage device,
an NVMe drive provides significantly faster data retrieval
compared to a SATA SSD while traditional HHDs are much slower
and typically not used in such scenarios anymore.
Overall, the NVMe storage greatly enhances database query performance
due to its rapid data access capabilities.
Compressing data server responses with Brotli or gzip can significantly improve
website performance by reducing the amount of data transferred over the network.
This provides a final stage of optimization on the response
being returned from the origin server.
On average, gzip compression can reduce the size of web content by 60 to 70 percent
while Brotli tends to provide even better compression rates
often reducing content size by 70 to 80 percent.
Enabling Brotli compression within Nginx is accomplished
through the use of the Brotli Nginx module.
The module can be compiled and installed alongside Nginx and loaded dynamically.
Analyze a server response for compression.
To determine if a request response was compressed with Brotli or gzip compression
you can use Chrome or Firefox developer tools to review the content encoding headers.
So you can follow these steps.
Open the developer tools in your browser.
Click on the Network tab in the developer tools.
Refresh the webpage or initiate the action you want to analyze.
This will populate the network panel with a list of requests made by the browser.
Then we'll find the requests we're interested in
such as the main document request or a specific resource like a CSS or a JavaScript file.
We'll click on the request to open the detailed view.
In the detailed view we'll look for the Headers tab.
This should be the default tab in both browsers.
Scroll down to the Response Headers section.
Then we'll check the value of the content encoding header.
If this response is compressed with gzip it will display gzip
and if it's compressed with Brotli it will display br.
If the header is absent or has a different value
the response is not compressed using either of these algorithms.
By examining the content encoding header in the developer tools
you can quickly determine if a request response was compressed with Brotli or gzip.
Serving requests from the NGINX CAS can result in significant performance improvements
as it eliminates the need for the request to traverse the entire stack
and access the backend services.
This can lead to reduced processing times and improved response times
resulting in a better user experience.
According to benchmarks serving requests from the NGINX CAS
can result in a 90% reduction in response times
compared to requests that traverse the entire stack.
This is due to the cache mechanism's ability to serve requests
directly from memory or disk reducing the time taken to process the request.
Furthermore serving requests from the NGINX CAS
can significantly reduce server load and improve scalability.
By reducing the number of requests that must be handled by backend services
like PHP, FPM or MySQL
the server can handle more requests concurrently
leading to improved performance and faster response times.
This is essential for a high-traffic website.
The UltraStack NGINX configuration adds an x-proxy cache HTTP header to responses
and the upstream cache status to NGINX access log entries.
The following three techniques explain how to identify whether the page being received
is a cache version served by NGINX.
We can use curl.
We can make a simple get request to the URL in question
and use grep to check the x-proxy cache header.
Also we can use chrome dev tools.
You can use F12 or the other shortcut to bring up the dev tools window
then click the network tab.
Pick the box that says disable cache
which will bypass chrome's internal cache
then reload the page to capture all of the network information.
Not disabling chrome's cache will allow you to see 304
not modified responses for static assets
which shows how the client side cache is working.
The following are the possible values for upstream cache status.
Miss the response was not found in the cache
and so was fetched from an origin server.
The response might then have been cached.
Bypass the response was fetched from the origin server
fetched from the cache because the response matched a proxy cache bypass directive.
Expired. The entry in the cache has expired.
The response contains fresh content from the origin server.
stale. The content is stale because the origin server is not responding correctly
and proxy cache use stale was configured.
Updating. The content is stale because the entry is currently being updated
in response to a previous request
and proxy cache use stale updating is configured.
Revalidated. The proxy cache revalidate
directive was enabled and nginx verified that the current cache content was still valid.
Hit. The response contains valid, fresh content
direct from the cache. Another technique to explain how to identify whether
the page being received is the cache version served by nginx
is using the nginx access log. You connect to the
server using SSH and read the access log with a tail or a
cat. The value assigned to UCS or the
upstream cache status will be one of the cache statuses we talked about before.
Using central's managed server tools, here's how you would enable nginx
proxy cache on your site. With nginx proxy cache configured
you may use the ultra stack utilities to
determine the cache hit rates for all requests to nginx.
While this is a tool specific to in-motion hosting
the information can be received using the third party nginx module
VTS. So in summary, using nginx proxy cache will help
drive performance for high traffic websites.
While the exact amount depends on the specific
workload of the website, a minimum of 4 GB and
2 vCPU cores is recommended when benchmarking your
resource needs on a high traffic website. In a high performance
server running MySQL, Redis, PHP, FPM, Apache, and
nginx, having enough RAM is critical to allow each services
caching techniques to work at their full potential. These services use
RAM to cache frequently accessed data and reduce the time taken
to retrieve it from disk or other storage devices. If the server
does not have enough RAM, the caching will not be as effective, leading
to longer processing times and slower website performance.
For instance, MySQL uses the NODB buffer pool to
cache frequently accessed data from the database, and Redis uses
memory to store frequently accessed data in key value pairs.
PHP FPM uses opcache to cache PHP
scripts, and nginx uses RAM to cache frequently requested
webpages and assets. If the server does not have sufficient
RAM, these caching techniques will not be as effective, and the
server may resort to swapping data in and out of slower
storage devices, leading to a slower response times and reduced server
capacity. Swap usage. To determine if a
Linux server is swapping, you can use the free command to view the system's
memory usage. If the swap value is greater than 0,
it indicates that the server is currently using swap space to store
data in memory. Additionally, you can use the vmstat command
to monitor the amount of swapping activity occurring on the server,
with the SI and SO values indicating the amount of memory
being swapped in and out, respectively. This example
does not use swap and is not swapping. OOM
OOM kills. To determine if a Linux server is experiencing
OOM, OOM or out of memory kills, you can check
the system logs for messages related to OOM events.
On most Linux distributions, the system log file is located
at var slash log slash messages, or var slash log slash syslog.
To view OOM related messages, you can search for
the keyword OOM using the grep command.
If OOM or OOM events are occurring, you'll see
entries that indicate which process or application was killed by
the OOM killer. Additionally, you can use tools like
DMESG and journal control to view kernel messages
related to OOM events. By having enough RAM on the server,
each service can utilize caching techniques to their fullest extent,
resulting in faster processing time, reduced
disk usage, and an overall better user experience.
There's a plugin that's super helpful when it comes to
optimizing WordPress sites. Let me show you how to install it really
easily with InMotion, but you can also install it basically
with any WordPress installation. So we'll go to optimize
and then WordPress. We have the W3
Total Cache. Now you can see that it improves SEO
and the user experience of your site by increasing website performance,
reducing load times via features like content delivery network integration
and the latest best practices. So basically I'm just
going to click here and W3 Total Cache is one of the most popular
ways to optimize and manage the cache for your WordPress site.
So this is going to result in faster
load times and less strain on your server, which is definitely going to
help with SEO. You can also enable this within the
WordPress dashboard if you don't have InMotion Central.
And I'll show you how to do that in a second. Right now I'm going to click on setup guide.
And this is going to help you set up things, but we're going to configure on our own
so I'll skip this setup guide. So before we
do that, I'm going to show you how you would install this with just WordPress
if you don't have the InMotion settings. So we just go to plugins
and then add new and then you just
search for W3
Total Cache.
So here is where you would install it and activate it, but we already have
installed and activated. So I'm going to go back to this performance
tab here. That's the W3 Total Cache tab.
And before I go through setting it up, let me just give you a little more context.
So by default WordPress is a dynamic
CMS. That means for every visitor request that WordPress has to process
it must first connect to the database to see if the requested page even
exists. In a lot of cases this might not be problematic
on a site that just doesn't receive much traffic. However, a sudden surge in traffic
caused by search engine bots or just a general increase in normal
traffic can quickly cause your WordPress site to use up a lot
of CPU resources from the server while trying to fulfill needless
duplicate requests again and again. You can counter
this increase in CPU usage by implementing a caching plugin.
What these do is cast the first visitor's request of a new page
to a plain HTML file on the server. Then when another visitor comes through
and requests the same page, so long as the page wasn't
updated in your admin section or updated by comment, the
cached HTML page will be served. This can greatly reduce
CPU usage of your WordPress site very easily.
As an example, let's say you had 100 views of your front page. Without caching
that would require the same database query to have to run 100 times
and every time it's just getting back the exact same data anyway. With the caching
plugin, only the first user would have the database query run to generate the
cached HTML file. Then the next 99 visitors would get
that cached HTML served to them right away without having to wait
for any database activity to complete. This is basically always a win-win
because your visitors don't have to wait as long for your pages to load and you're reducing
the impact of WordPress's requests on the server's performance.
Now I do want to note that database caching is not recommended for
shared hosting as the process is dependent on the disk speed of the server.
So due to the nature of shared system resources, disk speed
may be limited. And so database caching may adversely affect
the performance of the site. Really, what you want to do is experiment with different
caching techniques to see which one works best for your site. So now
let's see how to set up the w3 total caching plugin. I'm going to go to
the general settings here. Okay, and then I'm going to
make sure that the page cache is enabled. And then
for all these settings, we're just going to want to click either save
all settings, or save settings and purge caches
after you update the settings. One thing to keep in mind is
that you never want to use both nginx page caching
and total cache, that would slow things down and would cause
some conflicts with the caching. So you basically just want to use one
or the other. Another good feature to use is the
minify. You can see this is going to reduce the load time by decreasing the size
and number of CSS and JavaScript files. So it's, it's going to
make things load a lot quicker if you enable the
minify. If you are enabling minify, you're going to want to make sure
to check your WordPress site to make sure the site looks normal. If you see problems
then you can disable the minification.
And this is where you can use op cache to validate timestamps
so it will request the cache with the latest version.
And then you see the database cache.
Caching, it caches the database objects and this decreases the response
time of the site so it doesn't have to load from the database every time.
We're not we have it disabled because it's best if object
caching is not possible. By our case, we're going to use object
caching. And you also have the browser cache
and you can enable or disable a CDN.
And when you're choosing a CDN, you're going to have to choose
basically the CDN provider, which CDN you're going to use.
I'm actually going to disable this because
for a CDN you're going to have to sign up for
a CDN account. And make sure not to click the CDN button
if you don't have a CDN. That could actually mess some things up for your site.
Okay, I'm going to save this. And then
we'll go over to the page cache tab.
So we're going to just check the settings on this page.
We're going to we want to make sure we cast the front page, cast the feed,
cast SSL. We don't want to cast the URIs. We want to
cast the 404. Don't cast page for logged in users. Don't cast page for
the following user roles, just the administrator role. So we're just going to use all these
default settings. And this is just going to make sure we cast the page we want to
cache and don't cast the pages we don't want to cache. So I'll just save
settings and purge caches. So now I'm going to go to
the website, I'll just go to visit site here.
And I will go to view page source. And then if I go
all the way down to the bottom, I should see something.
Yep, performance optimized by w3 total cache.
So now I know that it's you it's working correctly
and it's installed correctly. So I'm back over on the total cache
setting page. I want to talk about cleaning your WordPress cache.
This is something you may need to do from time to time when using a caching plugin to speed up
WordPress. If you make changes to your WordPress site and don't see the changes when
visiting the updated page, you may need to clear your cache. This is because
the caching plugin could still be showing the cached version of your page.
So to force WordPress to show your most recent changes right away,
you can delete the cache. So basically just go to the
the main settings page and then we can
click empty all caches just like that.
All caches successfully emptied.
Now let's talk about browser
caching and some implementation techniques.
e tags. The e tag HTTP response header
is one that web servers and browsers use to determine
whether a resource in the browser's local cache matches the
one in the origin server. When a user revisits
the site, one of two things happen. It displays content
to the user in the browser if it's within the allowable cache
refresh time, the time to live. If content is out
of its cache time TTL expired, then
if it has an e tag, then it will need to send an e tag to the
resolved URL to see if it needs to refresh. Then if it gets
the matching e tag, then it will keep the content it has
no new downloading of content and set the existing content
TTL into the future, which makes it a viable
cached content for the TTL. And if it gets a different
e tag, then it will trigger a fresh download of the new
content. If it does not have an e tag, then it will
send a request out to get the potentially new content
and it will download that content regardless of whether it really is
new or not. It's important to note that the e tag
request and response is much, much smaller than a download of
content. As most websites do not change between
TTLs, the TTLs need to be low just in case the site
does change. Therefore, the e tag process is much more
efficient than TTLs by themselves.
So how do you check if your server response is using e tags?
Well, you open the developer tools in your browser using
the shortcut key or you can right click on the web page and click inspect.
Then click on the network tab in the developer tools.
Next, refresh the web page or initiate the action you want to analyze.
This will populate the network panel with a list of requests made by the browser.
Next, locate a specific resource like a CSS or JavaScript file.
Click on the request to open the detailed view. In the
detailed view, look for the headers tab.
Then scroll down to the response header section for the selected file
and check for the presence of an e tag.
How to configure e tags in W3 total cache. In your WordPress
admin dashboard, navigate to performance browser cache.
Scroll down to the general section. Check the box next to the
set entity tag e tag setting. On the same page, using
the same method, you can also enable or disable e tags for specific
files types, including CSS and JS, HTML
and XML media and other files. Finally,
press the save settings and purge caches button within each respective
setting box to save and apply the caching changes immediately.
Time to live. The time to
live value is the time that an object is stored in a caching system before it's
deleted or refreshed. In the context of CDNs,
TDL typically refers to the content caching, which is the process
of storing a copy of your website resources on CDN
proxies to improve paid load speed and reduce origin server bandwidth
consumption. TDLs are used for caching purposes, and
the value is stored in seconds. If the TDL value is set to a low number
like 3600 seconds, the data will be stored in the cache for
one hour. After one hour, a new version of the data needs to be retrieved.
If the TDL value is set to a high number like
86,400 seconds, the data will be stored in the cache for
24 hours. High TDL values cache your data longer
and lessen the frequency for retrieving new data. This gives your
website a performance boost by reducing the server's load, which
improves the user's experience. Let's look at how to set
TTL policies in w3 total cache.
You can make some limited changes to the TTL by
going to page cache, and then you scroll all the way down
to advanced.
Here's the advanced section. And then we can update
the garbage collection interval, which is how frequently the expired
cache data is removed. And then also the comment cookie lifetime.
This is going to reduce the default TTL for comment cookies
and it's going to reduce the number of authenticated user traffic.
Let's talk about the HTTP cache control
headers. So here are the different ones. There's
cache control max age. The max age directive specifies the maximum
number of times that a resource may be cast by a client or a
proxy server. After expiring, a browser must refresh
its version of the resource by sending another request to a server.
Cache control max age 3600 means
that the returned resource is valid for one hour after which the browser
has to request a new version. Cache control no cache.
The no cache directive tells a browser or a caching server not
to use the cache version of a resource and to request a new version of the
resource from the origin server. Cache control
no store. The no store directive tells browsers to never store
a copy of the resource and not to keep it in the cache.
This setting is usually used for sensitive information like credit card numbers
and ensures PCI compliance by not storing this type of data
in the cache. Cache control public.
The public response directive indicates that a resource can be cached
by any cache. This directive is useful for resources
that change infrequently and when the resource is intended for
public consumption. Cache control private.
The private response directive indicates that a resource is user-specific.
It can still be cached but only on a client
device. For example a web page response
marked as private can be cached by a browser but not a
content delivery network. Now let's see how to set
HTTP cache control headers in W3 total cache.
So to set up the cache control headers in W3 total cache
you go to the browser cache performance
browser cache and then we are going to determine
what are the cache control policies will be for
some different files. So I can scroll down
to the CSS and JavaScript section
and then we'll set the cache
control header. Now we'll select the cache
control policy and I'll just select this one
cache with max age. And then you can do the same
thing for HTML and XML. We can set the
cache control header, choose the policy, and then
for the media and other files we can set the cache control
header and set the policy. And then you always
want to make sure to save changes and purge caches.
Cache Busting
cache busting is a technique used to force a browser or caching service
to retrieve a new version of a resource rather than using the
cached version. One way to do this is by using query parameters
such as a timestamp or a version number
in the URL of the resource. For example, instead of requesting
resource at the URL example dot com slash style dot CSS
a cache busting URL would look like example dot com slash style dot CSS
and then you get the version one two three four where V equals one two
three four is the query parameter. This query parameter
can be a timestamp or a version number and will be ignored
by the server but it will force the browser or caching server to treat
the request as a new request rather than using the cached version
of the resource. This technique is often used for static resources
like like styleship scripts or images that are intended
to be cached but they may not be needed to be updated frequently.
By appending a query parameter to the URL
a new version of the resource will be retrieved each time the query parameter changes.
This technique is commonly used to ensure that the client gets the
latest version of the resources after they're updated on the
server side. To enable cache busting in WCTurtle
cache we'll go to the performance and
the browser cache section and then
we just have to go to prevent
caching of objects after settings change.
This will add a random string at the end of static asset
URLs.
Cache storage is a finite resource so every bit of storage performance
matters. Caching at proxy servers is one of the ways to reduce the
response time perceived by web users. You have to choose
between ease of use versus complicated configurations
versus your needs. You have to look at the CDN level edge caching
the server nginx proxy cache, the WordPress
plugins application level caching. What do you have now? What's your budget?
CDNs can be expensive. Where's your audience
in relation to your server? What do we want to guide the user to do?
Cache replacement algorithms play a central role in reducing
response times by selecting specific websites assets for caching
so that a given performance metric is maximized. They do this by
deciding which objects can stay and which objects should be evicted
the next time the website is accessed. The different policies are
least recently used. This replaces the cache line that has been in the cache
longest with no references to it. Then first in first out
replaces the cache line that has been in the cache longest.
Least frequently used replaces the cache line that has experienced
the fewest references or random. Pick a line at random from the candidate
lines.
Page caching refers to caching the content of a whole page
on the server side. Later when the same page is requested again, its
content will be served from the cache instead of regenerating it from scratch.
A page from a WordPress website contains
dynamic content. PHP scripts, JavaScript, and SQL queries.
Executing this dynamic content is very resource heavy
and takes a lot of time. Page caching allows for forming a
part of the website into static HTML. With page
cache enabled, website content displays faster for a visitor with less load
on the server. It's one of the most efficient ways to improve your website performance.
Object caching is the process that involves storing
database queries to serve a specific piece of data on the
subsequent server request. As a result, there will be fewer
queries sent to the database and the result is your website will load much
faster. WordPress object cache. The idea of
object cache is that WordPress core themes and plugins may store some data
that is frequently accessed and rarely changed in the
object store. This is so these objects will not have to be retrieved and processed
on each request. WP object cache
is WordPress's class for caching data.
And by default, the object cache is non-persistent. This means that data
stored in the cache resides in memory only and only for
the duration of the request. Cache data will not be stored
persistently across page loads unless you install a persistent
caching plugin. Ultimately, object caching will reduce
the total number of database queries required for each page load.
When the CPU does not have to rebuild this box of data, your response time
will decrease.
Once the server and database have been tuned for performance,
the next step is to ensure the application is optimized for performance.
This can be done by leveraging techniques designed to deliver
assets much more efficiently or removing any unnecessary
data from them resulting in faster transfers. The following
are some of the most effective techniques you can use when it comes to optimizing
your WordPress site for speed. But it's not an exhaustive
list. When focusing on page website performance, there are some essential
tasks you can complete to help you achieve the performance results
you're looking for. These tasks include configuring caching,
following best practices for elements that can introduce layout
shifts, and adjusting your assets to ensure they are configured
for the fastest possible delivery to your visitors.
One, page caching. WordPress is a dynamic program
by default. So the easiest way to speed things up is to create a static
version of your website pages and use redirects to serve those
cached files instead of calculating the result again with PHP and MySQL.
This cache can be stored on the disk in the server's RAM
or if you're using a CDN on a point of presence or edge server.
If you're storing the page cache on the web server, then it's
recommended to use disk enhanced storage. So the web server
redirects can serve the cache prior to the request reaching
PHP, essentially making the site load faster by using the
static files instead of recreating them with queries and calculations.
Storing page cache on a CDN at
the edge is a practice known as full site delivery
or acceleration, where the website is served by sending a
cached version of the website from a geographic location near the visitor
as opposed to the request reaching out to the origin server
where the data lives. This removes
location introduced latency
from the equation, making websites much faster for all of
your visitors to object caching with Redis. By default the
object cache in WordPress is not persistent. This means that data stored
in the cache resides in memory for the duration of the request and is often
removed after the response is delivered. To store these cached objects
for reuse, you can use a plugin that connects the WordPress
cache to Redis, a RAM based service that is used for
persistent object storage. W3 Total Cache will allow you to
use object caching with Redis. Redis stores the data as keys in the
web server's memory, which allows for retrieval of the data to happen much faster
than the WordPress method, which caches those objects to the options
table in the database by default. Three, leveraging common
UX patterns. When adding elements such as fonts, carousels,
banners to your website, you want to ensure that you are following best practices.
These types of elements can have a negative impact on Core Web Vitals
if not implemented correctly. A great example of this is not explicitly
setting proper placeholders or dimensions for images, videos, iframes
or other similar embedded content throughout your page. When the content
is loaded, this can cause layout shift and Core Web Vitals has very
specific metrics, as the moving page can create a bad user experience for
your visitor. Learning custom fonts on your website is another example where things can
go wrong. Adding them incorrectly can delay the text rendering or even cause
layout shifts. Typically your browser would delay displaying text until the font
is loaded, which can also impact your FCP or
LCP. If the text does load prior to your web font
and there are different sizes, layout shifts will occur and directly impact
your CLS score. Four, minification. When developing a website,
most programmers tend to use spacing and comments to make code readable for both
themselves and others. Minification is a technique used to reduce
load times on a website by removing unnecessary characters and comments from the
code for faster delivery and rendering. This technique can be used
on HTML, CSS, and JavaScript files and can dramatically
improve your site's performance. To minify your assets with W3 Total
Cache, you'll need to enable it in general settings. There's an automatic mode which attempts
to handle the heavy lifting for you, but if you have issues with it, you'll need to
enable manual mode and add the assets you wish to be minified yourself under
the minify page. There is a help wizard for setting up
minify, which you can use to specify the template to use when loading the asset.
Five,
concatenation. The term concatenation refers to the action of linking
things together in a series. In the context of a website performance,
this means combining multiple CSS and JavaScript files into a few files
to deliver the assets the browser needs faster with less requests.
In W3 Total Cache, concatenating files is an option
in general settings under minify. Checking the box will allow you to combine
the asset files into one of three different files in the DOM.
One in the head, one in the body, or one at the footer before
closing the document. Six, eliminate render blocking resources.
Render blocking resources is essentially coding your website files,
usually CSS and JavaScript, that prevents a webpage from loading quickly.
To ensure your site loads as efficiently as possible, you can specify
attributes that tell the browser how to download the code in relation to the other
site assets. When concatenating and minifying files
using W3 Total Cache, you also have the option of embedding them before
the the close of the document's head tag, or after the body tag.
To improve performance, you have the option of setting rel attributes
for the assets such as async or defer, which will tell the browser
when and how to load the file. The minify wizard in Total Cache
will allow you to specify which JS and CSS files load by template,
allowing you to have to have fine tune control over which assets load
when and where. Seven, preconnect and prefetch
DNS hints. If your site is using multiple third party scripts, the
location those scripts are hosted on will be considered a cross
origin domain. That third party domain will need to be resolved to an IP
address for the browser to download the file and complete the request. The time it
takes for this DNS resolution to take place can introduce latency
into the page load. And using preconnect and prefetch will instruct the browser to
handle this prior to fetching the asset. This can help remove the latency
introduced by resolving a large number of DNS requests for assets in the background.
Using DNS prefetch and preconnect
links will help your page load faster by performing these operations
for later use. The DNS prefetch will do a DNS
lookup while preconnect will establish the connection to the server.
This connection established will also include a TLS handshake
if served over HTTPS. The preconnect hint
should be used sparingly and only for the most critical assets being used in the viewport
during the initial page load. For non-critical assets, using
only the DNS prefetch hint is recommended.
Eight, image optimization. Image optimization refers to
the practice of a website delivering the highest quality image with the right format
with the right format, resolution, and dimensions for the
device and viewport accessing them. This is done with the
intent of keeping the file size as small as possible. There are several layers
when dealing with optimizing your images, including removing metadata,
converting to a different format, resizing, and lazy loading. One of the ways to
reduce an image's file size is to remove any metadata attached to the file.
This static can include information about the camera used to take the picture,
GPS coordinates, the file's owners, comments, a thumbnail, and more.
There are several types of metadata that can be added to the images
including EXIF, IPTC, XMP.
Removing this data will help to decrease the file size of the image.
An added benefit is that removing metadata keeps these details from being
publicly shared. WebP is a compression format
for images developed by Google. When optimizing your images
for speed, using WebP is the recommended format for websites.
Most modern browsers now support the WebP image format. There are many WordPress
plugins that offer this type of image conversion and most even assist with
redirects to automate the process and a fallback option in case the browser
does not support the WebP format. W3 Total Cache has a service for
conversion of images and redirects under media library when
image service extension is activated. Dynamic image resizing.
When different devices are used to access your webpage, the image size
needed will vary depending on the visitor's viewport. Dynamic image sizes
can be used to make each of these devices load the image with a size
tailored specifically to the viewport where the site is being rendered.
A great example of this would be the hero image on your website. While a desktop would
likely need the full size version of the image, the
narrow viewport of a mobile device may only need an image that is 20%
of that size. Providing the browser with the smaller size would reduce
the time it needs to download the file and display it. There are many WordPress
plugins and CDN providers that offer dynamic resizing for images.
The solution you choose could be based on your audience. If your visitors
are mostly local and your traffic is not high volume, a CDN's cost
for this service may outweigh the benefits to you, so using a WordPress plugin may be
your best option. 9 Lazy loading images and other
embeds. Lazy loading is the practice of identifying non-critical
assets and ensuring they only load later as needed to render
the page in the browser. In the context of images, lazy loading is usually
based on a user interaction such as scrolling, and loads
images needed as the user gets near them. Lazy loading allows the first render
to happen faster, as it instructs the browser to only load the critical
resources needed to display what is being rendered in the viewport.
Then, as you scroll, the application can detect when resources are
needed and initialize the download. W3TrollCache offers lazy
loading for images. Finally, using image facades for interactive
elements. One of the biggest issues authors run across is having
multiple video embeds from providers such as YouTube or Vimeo.
Loading these videos will force your site to do DNS lookups,
make connections to these third-party servers in the background, and download
the elements needed to render the content. Providing an image that is
stirred from your site's domain as an interaction point to trigger loading these types
of content embeds can save you precious time rendering your webpage.
It also saves a user from downloading JavaScript and CSS for an
element they are not going to use, as the video does not render unless the user
specifically clicks on the image anchor link to trigger it. This is also
true for other interactive elements such as chat embeds or other interactive elements
that are not hosted on your server and are being served to your visitor
from a remote service.
Okay, now that we've done some optimization
to our WordPress page, let's enter the WordPress URL in the
page speed insight and analyze it again.
And we can
see the numbers are better. Our performance is up
and our performance is up on mobile
and our performance is up on desktop. This was a basic
overview for configuring your performance. And there are additional
ways to drill down into your configuration when aiming for higher scores.
A great example of this is using custom page templates for your most visited
and important landing pages and using the minify help wizard to
only load the critical CSS and JavaScript assets on those pages
if they're needed. Some plugins like contact forms can load their resources
on all pages, even if there's not a contact form embedded.
You've reached the end of the course, you've learned about key metrics important to
website performance, and you've learned a bunch of things you can do to
optimize the performance of your website. Thanks for watching.